hey youtubers it's Charlie and since
we've only got a couple more episodes
left and Walking Dead this season I
thought it was time to do some more
predictions so here are 10 things that I
think are going to happen or not happen
in some cases if you're finding me for
the first time I do a weekly Walking
Dead giveaway just as a way to say thank
you to all you guys for being so awesome
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment the next
round will start on Sunday whenever I
post my review video so let's predict
some awful awful things careful for
spoilers if you're not caught up on
season 4 though here we go number 10
Lizzie and mica are basically Ben and
Billy from the comic books so based on
what's happening on the show right now
around this time in the comics two
little twin boys appeared named Billy
and Ben Ben started torturing and
killing animals just like Lizzy has been
doing ultimately been in the comics
kills his brother Billy he's completely
nuts
and based on the way Lizzy has been
behaving since the season came back
especially with baby Judith it seems
likely that she and Mika are basically
taking the place of those brothers in
the teaser for episode 14 you can see
Mika on the ground with walkers coming
after and Carole crying it implies that
Mika will either get bitten or die based
on Billy and Ben's storyline that would
suggest that Lizzy will then kill Mika
to prevent her from turning so yes she's
murdering her sister but she is infected
so it won't be quite as bad as it was in
the comics the show does that a lot
where they change things from the comics
so that they're still really bad but not
quite as graphic
so essentially Lizzy will end up killing
Mika or try to kill her and Tyreese or
Carol will stop her Ben's plot in the
comics involves Carl so they will have
to change things a little bit no matter
what though number 9 Glenn and Maggie
will be reunited a lot of you were
asking if Glenn was geographically
behind Maggie
in the last episode based on the amount
of time the show has dedicated to
showing her insane finger painting scene
I think that he is at the very least
they'll meet up at terminus in the
finale it's hard to guess where everyone
is chronologically just because the
episodes jump around in time for
instance remember that person in Joe's
gang that Daryl ran into he's the same
guy that ended up on the floor in front
of Rick earlier so what's been happening
as we jump from group to group is that
they're telling the story of everyone
during the same period of time most of
them have been on foot too so they
haven't really gone that far from the
prison forgetting for a sec what happens
the comics to their characters I think
they will at least get that moment of
reunion just the relief of having found
each other
inevitably something awful will probably
happen to them right after that though
number eight all of the groups will meet
up at terminus I talked about this a
little bit in my last Q&A video but
there have been so many visual
references to the terminus for all the
groups it would be crazy if they didn't
all end up there Glen is the furthest
away just because he spent a couple of
hours on the road to Washington DC but
we saw him staring at a terminus map
last week there's this really cool old
anton chekhov quote saying that a gun
must never be placed on stage if it's
not going to go off it's all about the
narrative of a story meaning don't make
promises you don't intend to keep and
showing Glenn with the terminus map is
kind of like a promise that he's going
there the only real question is is when
he's finally going to be Maggie either
in the finale or right before the finale
we still don't have any information
about episode 15 yet
number 7 Daryl's new group will not be
the hunters or the Savior's right now
they're being referred to as the
Marauders who appeared a long time ago
in the comics but because Joe's group is
a lot bigger than the Marauders they're
a lot closer visually to the hunters
there's a couple of problems with
calling them the hunters though number
one we haven't seen them eat anyone yet
and two they're very disorganized and
chaotic please refer back to jerk-offs
strangling each other while Rick hid
under the bed the other option is the
Savior's but the reason I don't think
that the Savior's is because that group
is heavily tied to negan in the
sanctuary which based on everything
Robert Kirkman said is a season 5 thing
if they're not hunters not Marauders and
not saviors then they're just a new
group that the show is created I do
think that they're attached to the
terminus though I don't think they're
just a random group of bandits roaming
the countryside number 6
terminus will be a version of hilltop
colony the hilltop colony is a place
Rick and the survivors go before
Alexandria safe zone and before the
sanctuary additionally it has one
specific character that I'll talk about
in a sec hilltop colony as a story point
sets up a lot of things we know are
coming like negan and Alexandria it also
provides a place for an antagonist
that's not really a huge character like
the governor or negan Robert Kirkman
said that the whole reason and not doing
negan right away was just to give the
story time to breathe between those two
characters
they're like the two most epic villains
in the comic book so they just want to
do those characters one right after the
other number five there won't be any
negan
but the Gareth character will be a
version of Jesus Jesus is one of the
main characters at the hilltop colony
that I just mentioned his real name is
Paul Monroe and he's not really as much
of a villain as a character that just no
one trusts he is a really good fighter
so if Gareth is the Jesus character we
will probably get to see him fight
Abraham and be shown like in the comic
books the really important thing that
Jesus does is is let all the other
survivors know about the existence of
negan and the Savior's mostly that
they're awful it's also important to
note that hilltop
and Jesus are a precursor to Alexandria
in the name of episode 16 the finale is
a so it just makes sense that this is
how stuff is getting teased out on the
show number four
Gareth took Beth to terminus because
there was a cross on the back of the car
and the whole house looked like a trap
everyone thought the hunters or the
Savior's might be involved but I think
the cross could also be a visual
reference to the Jesus character who is
a little shady but well-meaning that
would mean the Gareth did take Beth but
only to help her which still doesn't
answer the question as to the house trap
or why someone would have led the
walkers to the house it's also possible
that the Gareth character is a
combination of Jesus from the hilltop
colony and the Gabriel character Gabriel
story did involve the hunters and Dale
getting captured and it happens in the
comics before to the hilltop colony
story so the show could also just be
mashing all of those things together
number three everyone's going to learn
about negan negan is the leader to the
Savior's a really sinister group that
exerts money and does terrible things to
people in exchange for protection from
the walkers mostly at the hilltop colony
by all accounts he won't be on the show
in a big way at least until season five
everyone learns about him while they're
at hilltop where negan gets a lot of his
supplies his story crosses over into
Alexandria safe zone so if the finale is
going to tease Alexandria which it
sounds like it is it will also have to
tease negan Carl ends up getting tied up
in a lot of this plot which means that
Chandler Riggs will potentially have a
much more interesting story next season
which i think is great
and I kind of think of negan as being
like the most evil version possible of
Rick which means there's a real
potential for marrying Carl's relate
ship with Rick and just like negan being
the evil version of Rick I kind of think
of the Savior's as being like the most
evil version of the survivors number two
everyone's also going to learn about the
Alexandria safe zone the Alexandria safe
zone is kind of like the next prison
location in the story a big Walden area
where everyone is safe from walkers the
name of the finale is a and that just
seems like the biggest possible teaser
you could do for Alexandria a lot of
that story is tied up with negan and the
Savior's so I don't think anyone's going
to get there until season five a lot of
the people thought the radio message
Daryl heard was from there but really I
think that was just from the terminus
and my number one prediction for the
rest of season four instead of just one
big death there's actually gonna be to
remember how Lizzie is basically turning
into or already is the Ben character
meaning she'll either try to kill Mika
or will get killed herself either way I
think it means one of the girls is going
to die my other prediction is a little
more complicated there was a rumor
earlier this season that a character
that's still alive in the comics is
going to be the one who's gonna die on
the show which really narrows it down a
lot most of the people that are dead in
the comics are already dead on the show
plus there's the fact that a few of the
characters in the show aren't in the
comics so we have to exclude them
meaning Daryl and Beth are probably safe
my earliest prediction was that it would
be Maggie who would die depending on
whether or not the show is going to
bring out the hunters I may have to
revise this but for now I'm sticking
with her so let me know who do you think
is going to die and do you think that
Lizzie is going to try to kill Mika or
baby Judith based on the teaser for the
next episode in Carol's face it looks
like someone is definitely going to die
also like I said next round of the
giveaway starts whenever I post my
review for episode 14 be sure to
subscribe to get that that's gonna be on
Sunday remember we only have three more
episodes to go in the season right now
click here for my last Walking Dead
video and click here to learn about my
other predictions for season 4 some of
them have already come true so far thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tonight
high fives
you